hello welcome to our webinar on meeting
the demand of increasing NGS capacity
with high throughput automation a
collaboration between the Center for
genomics and bioinformatics beckman
coulter and alumina I'm Melissa Jackson
with beckman coulter and I will be the
moderator we're pleased to bring you
this panel presentation by Zack Smith
from the center for genomics and
bioinformatics he is a project scientist
Mary Blair a senior application
scientist at beckman coulter and Dave
delana a marketing manager from alumina
a few housekeeping items before we begin
the presentation will run about 40 to 45
minutes then we will follow it with a
question-and-answer session that will be
moderated by myself you can enter
questions throughout the presentation by
clicking on the green button on the
bottom left hand side and you can also
increase the screen size by clicking on
the little frame icon that's located on
the far right after the presentation
please feel free to visit beckman
coulter spoof where we will continue
chat around this topic and others and
you can download information about our
genomic products and solutions with that
I will get on with the presentation and
I will turn this over to Zack Smith Jack
hello Lisa R thank you for coming to
this presentation my name is Zack Smith
on a project scientist with the center
for genomics and bioinformatics at
Indiana University I'd like to start by
just going through our agenda real
briefly first we'll discuss the
transcriptome and RNA seek and why it's
important and then I will pass it off to
Dave Delano from alumina to discuss
their RNA stranded kits and mary blair
from Pegman will then discuss about the
development of this automation protocol
and then finally I'll go through the QC
data that we've generated as a part of
this
volpe hi seek and my seek alumina
platforms so the saran scriptum is
extraordinarily important it represents
the summation of all RNA species that
play a role in the transmission and
attenuation of information being passed
from genome to the podium it includes a
wide variety of RNA species including
standard mrnas as well as smaller names
micro RNAs and non-coding RNAs at
various lengths we are just now
beginning to understand how increasingly
important how important the
transcriptome is to really understand
genomics in the modern times the
transcriptome drives huge numbers of
changes in an organism so a couple of
things that we look at here at our
Institute is a changes in response to
environmental stimuli so on your left
you'll see a couple of the common water
flea Daphne fuel ex and the flea on the
far left has been reared under standard
laboratory conditions it looks quite
transparent and the flea on the right is
very red it was raised in hypoxic
environment and so it's over expressing
hemoglobin to compensate that a little
oxygen in the water this is a fairly
straightforward ship that you can see
with the eye but there are hundreds of
other genes that are being up regulated
and down regulated as a result of just
as one simple environmental stimuli and
what we would like to know as
researchers is you know under other
circumstances such as increased metals
and acid stress what'll you know what
genes are we seeing being transcribed in
the organism from a medical standpoint
the transcriptome can be used to see
observe shifts between cancerous and
non-cancerous cell fates and so that's
extraordinarily important in on gene
research so traditionally RNA seek has
been sort of blind to strand information
so during the library construction of
traditional RNA seek library strand
information is lost
and that's a problem because it leaves
us with an incomplete picture of the
transcriptome by ignoring a number of
things like anti-synth expression and it
also in does not allow us to be as
accurate as we can be in looking for
measurements of overlapping genes and
looking for splice junctions so if we
could preserve the strand information
during library construction that
actually gives us a higher percentage of
uniquely alignable reads which reduced
your sample costs actually increases
your or that the value of your
experiment by maximizing your return on
your investment additionally there are
some papers including the encode and
modern code projects that seem to think
that something like seventy five percent
or more of a genome might be transcribed
at some point in the water flea daphnia
we have identified in addition to about
thirty eight thousand genes large
numbers of what we're referring to as
transcriptionally active region which
show variations in transcription on
application of metals and such so the
transcriptome is very important and
getting that strand information is also
very important another reason why strand
information is important is the model
system that you're working and so these
are three very familiar friends in
evolutionary biology that the software
milana gastric fruit floyd the
watercress our analysis ballerina and
the comet lab mouse these are systems
have been worked on in biology for many
many years now have very highly well
they have well annotated genomes for
it'll you know and the model systems and
our have been very heavily worked on
these are very good workers organisms
for doing really good biology however
here at IU we have a number of
researchers who are trying to answer
some very interesting biology questions
with non model system so you can see
there the world bird is the jungle so we
have a lab on campus that's using that
as a model for social interactions
we have the sea urchin Helio sedaris
which is on the bottom left both the
vaguest eres the horn beetle and ferns
and all kinds of plants that were
working on including strawberries and
avocados systems where there are not
very well-developed reference genomes
and so if we can maximize the return on
our transcript own research by getting
very accurate mappings of splice
junctions and such we can leverage the
somewhat under-represented reference
genomes as well as we can so it's very
important for a non model system
additionally the ever increasing
capacity of alumina sequencers are
tempting our researchers towards larger
and larger studies we have labs on
campus that are interested in looking at
entire populations of animals from on a
transcriptome level only as a result now
looking at impacts and environmental
stresses on whole populations so that
will give you a lot of samples to prep
we have other researchers who are
interested in time course experiments
say following the activation of genes in
plants after pollination so I'm looking
at you know one-hour intervals after
pollination we have other researchers
who are interested in looking and
actually getting to the point where we
can do replicates of our RNA seek
experiments doesn't just to verify that
the variations that we're seeing in the
expression are not driven not by library
instruction that are actually biological
ravel relevant and so all of these all
these expansions result in more samples
more libraries to prep and they were
really ideally benefit from decreases in
cost both time and money or library
construction so that's what's really
pushing us towards the automation of
each strand kits and so with that I'm
going to pass control to Dave toll on
Omar alumina representative Thank You
Zach I appreciate it and it's my
pleasure to be here today to talk to all
of you about rusik stranded mrna sample
preparation kits so our goal in
designing these kids is to provide the
clearest and most complete picture of
the tree
script dome we went about achieving this
by leveraging our existing core true
seek RNA chemistry and the high coverage
and informative that it provides and
item to that very precise strand
information not going to talk in a
minute about how i went about achieving
that we also further streamline the
workflow and add a greater flexibility
to fit a wide range of study designs
with quick configuration student from
below sample number and high sample
number study designs so how do we
capture strand information well many of
you may be familiar with the study
entitled comprehensive comparative
analysis of strand-specific RNA
sequencing methods so this is published
a couple years ago in the journal Nature
Methods by group over the Broad
Institute and this group compared seven
strand-specific RNA library prep
produções looking at multiple categories
related to data quality including stream
specificity the evenness and the
continuity of transcript coverage as
well as the coverage of five prime and
refine patents which as many of you know
can be a challenge to capture so this
group ultimately selected fragmentation
random expert based dutp as their top
method stating that the dtp method
provided the most compelling overall
balance of criteria so aluminum
basically further optimized this
protocol by improving the percentage
randomness and also shortening the total
ass a time so how does a DTM dtp method
work well the first step is RNA
fragmentation so for those of you who
are familiar with working with RNA you
know that it tends to form secondary
structure so the goal here is to
maximize the fraction of that
transcriptome sequence is going to be
available as a substrate or cdna
synthesis the next step is going to be
first-strand cdna synthesis this is
going to be driven by random hexamers
and the purpose of that is to maximize
that uniformity of coverage across a
transcriptome once that step is complete
you then go to second strand cdna
synthesis and this is again driven by
random hexamers to bolster that coverage
uniformity now with this step you're
going to swap out the dt TP in the
nucleotide mix with dutp and the reason
for that will be apparent in a second so
your next step is going to be to ligate
your adapters and for those of you who
are familiar with our chemistry you know
that we have two adapters the p5 and the
p7 adapters which are specific to the 5
prime and 3
prime ends of your inserts respectively
so once that step is done you want to
amplify so are you want to enrich for
the successfully ligated inserts through
pcr amplification so with this step we
is a high-fidelity tack and that tack is
unable to process through dutp
incorporated template as a result of
that only one of those two templates is
going to successfully amplify and
because you know the orientation of the
p5 and p7 adapters relatives that
original RNA transcript you've now
captured strand information so I also
mentioned that true seeks fragmentation
random hexamer chemistry provides high
uniformity of coverage and that point is
illustrated in the figure below so if
you look at the bottom left this is
based on a library generated using the
true Sikh RNA chemistry and on the
x-axis you're looking at the transcript
from the five prime end of the left side
the three prime end on the right and on
the y-axis you're looking at the level
of coverage that's provided and we can
basically see here is you're getting
extremely even coverage across that
whole span for the five prime to three
prime end now in contrast to that I go
to the right side this is a similar
experiment one with an alternative
method and what you can see here is that
rather than seeing a straight line
indicating very uniform coverage what
you're seeing is peaks and valleys with
very high coverage on the far left side
and the five prime end as well as on the
far right in the three prime end but you
have some gaps in between so the
repercussions on the experimental design
and the quality of the study are that if
you're looking for such features as
alternative transcripts or gene fusions
the likelihood of your successfully and
with high confidence capturing that
information and making those calls is
going to depend in part on where within
the sequence those features happen to
lie and the only way around that is to
increase the overall output they were
all sequencing output per sample which
may ultimately mean fewer samples that
you can run per lane so overall because
you'll be bolstering coverage and
regions where it's not necessary this
means a less cost efficient experiment
so in short the higher that coverage
uniformity the more cost-efficient your
study is going to be so this line is
just showing the different
configurations we have available for the
trees experian of mrna kiss there are
two LT or low throughput can
duration set a and set B each of these
is going to give you 12 24 total
available indexes we also offer an HT or
high throughput kit so this is designed
for higher throughput larger sample
number studies it gives you 96 samples
and offers you 96 indexes so this is
going to be didn't give you a little bit
more flexibility in terms of the number
of indexes you could let per lane I also
wanted to take a second excuse me it's a
plug in an additional kitten our
portfolio thats related to that study to
subscribe well the true Sikh stranded
total RNA sample preparation kits so
these kids are are based on the same
core chemistry of the kit that I
mentioned with the exception that they
have integrated rival zero ribosomal RNA
reduction chemistry which enables the
capture of old coding and non-coding RNA
very importantly this chemistry is
robust with low quality including FFPE
samples and there are multiple
configurations available that will suit
a wide range of study designs including
for specific species as well as a kit
designed specifically for blood-derived
RNA I also want to mention that I have
it under advisement that Beckman will
soon be offering an automation solution
for these configurations as well and
with that I will pass it back over
excuse me to Mary Blair thanks Dave now
we're going to switch gears a little bit
and talk about why you would want to
automate your library construction
process as we all know good library
construction is essential for quality
sequencing results by automating library
construction it allows you to
standardize your procedure free up your
time for data analysis increase your
throughput while achieving the same
quality results reduce opportunities for
cross contamination and protect users
from handling hazardous materials such
as samples or reagents now we can
discuss what you can consider when you
start automating your process everybody
handles automation a little differently
but there's a particular process I like
to follow first I review the protocol
and start to map out the process so that
i can highlight any incubation times or
temperatures that are required and any
volumes that are being transferred
all the various reagent types that are
used and any start and stop points
within a protocol that allow for partial
processing of samples safely from there
I look at which platform I want to
automate on beckman coulter offers three
different levels of automation starting
with the biomat 4000 for lower through
pine a biomechanics p for medium through
pine and a biome fxp for higher
throughput usually I'm given a
throughput requirement and I choose the
platform that meets that however I can
also be given a platform and then
determine what the third code is capable
of meeting on that particular platform
with that particular application while
i'm looking at platforms i also need to
decide if there are any devices that
need to be integrated that co-culture
has many different options for
integrations to handle your heating and
cooling any thermal cycling shaking or
special specialty things like vacuum
filtration and centrifugation after I'm
deciding on the platforms and devices to
integrate i can start configuring a deck
layout for the illumina applications we
chose to use the biomech FXP duel hybrid
in order to get 96 samples with minimal
amount of user interaction we can also
use the biomech in XP and the biomech
4000 but we would have to use a lower
throughput requirement in order to use
those choosing the biomech FXP allowed
us to use the 4 by 3 alps so that we
have a maximum of space for lab where a
96 tip wash station so that we can cut
down to consumable costs and wash our
tips during all the am pure clean up
steps a static pelletier to keep the
reagents chilled an orbital shaker to
cut down the overall processing time by
eliminating some of the tip mixing and
to have space for the optional T robot
so that it can be a more walk away
solution with having your incubations
handled on deck Zach and I work together
to build the biomech method and we did
this by outlining the protocol within
biomech software biomech software allows
you to easily build a method by using
these drag-and-drop GUI icons that you
can
figure to meet your protocol after we
were finished building the bio mcmuffin
we started to do water tests so that we
can get the initial pipetting
optimization complete if the method flow
down check all our lab or definitions
and our lab or moves on the system then
we can do pipe heading optimization
using like reagents I like to use
glycerol solutions to mimic master mixes
or if I have any available use expired
reagents doing this allows me to cut
down on my developmental costs after
we're done with pipetting optimization
we start our live sample runs we started
working with a small sample bunch such
as eight samples and then worked our way
up to doing the full ninety six samples
doing this allows us to see if there's
any column effects that are taking place
between a small sample batch and a large
sample batch and for the illumina
applications I apply to basic user
interface using HTML and I don't always
do this for all of my applications if
it's a static process or a single
customer I will typically tend to skip
this part there are some things you need
to consider when moving from a manual to
an automated process and there are some
challenges that can happen we can't
easily manage those for the illuminant
application we had to realize that lab
where selection can affect the quality
of results we chose to use a half deep
96 well plate for our amp your clean up
steps because it allowed us to use
shaking instead of tip mixing which cut
down time and made it more consistent we
also use the bio-rad pcr hard shell
plates because these plates are very
automation friendly and allow us to move
the plates on the deck and in and out of
the T robot so that we can debate
without having to have user interaction
for the static pelletier we developed
our own to block so that we could keep
the reagents chilled and we also chose
to use AV bottom shape tube because this
allows us to cut out on the amount of
dead volume so that we can keep our
asian costs down low for other reagents
such as ethanol when we were more
concerned with evaporation and its
hydroscopic nature we actually used an
overage amount in order to compensate
for those overall the hardest thing is
actually pinpointing all the little
allowances that people do on a manual
process and then translating those to an
automated process I've worked with some
chemistry in the past with a brand of
water had a great effect on the efficacy
of the kit however in this instance the
alumina chemistry was actually very
robust and very easy to work with so why
did we develop the alumina true Sikh
stranded mrna method sweet well we
wanted to help you increase your
throughput reduce errors and help
streamline the workflow the suite of
method includes the cdna synthesis and
library construction method and amp your
XP cleanup kappa qpcr setup method and
the normalization and pulling method and
each one of these is capable of
processing up to 96 samples the first
method is actually two methods in one
and this is where you prepare your
libraries it allows you to select a kid
so you can use either the true Sikh
stranded Emma or naked or the true Sikh
RNA version to kit you can also enter
your number of samples anywhere from 1
to 96 choose whether you want to
incubate on deck or off deck and then if
you want to run cdna synthesis or
library construction here we have cdna
synthesis selected and so we can choose
to perform poly a purification and
fragmentation through second strand
synthesis or if we uncheck the perform
poly a purification we can now bring
already purified mrna onto the system if
we change the method that we're running
to library construction it also updates
the options so if we choose to run the
true Sikh RNA version 2 kid we now have
the option to perform and repair we
still have the ability to choose the
number of samples for processing and how
we're handling our incubations there's
also some options that are included for
the adapter we allow you to pause for
edition of the adapter lab where to the
deck in order to prevent evaporation of
your adapters you can also select which
lab or type you're going to use you can
use the aluminum wrap clade or a
customer defined 96-well plate or 24
position to brac and you can use a
transfer by file option in order to hit
pick we also allow you to alter the
volume of sample be
used in your PCR set up the second
method is also two methods in one where
it runs am pure XP and your qpcr set up
however this one's a little bit
different than your library prep method
this one you can either run each method
separately or you can run them together
in order to minimize the amount of user
interaction with the system the user
interface for amp your XP has some
options for the number of samples that
you're cleaning up your pc our sample
volume that you're using the volume of
NPR XP and how much you want to dilute
in the qpcr set up user interface has
many options available as well you can
choose between doing a 96-well format or
a 384-well qpcr plate format how you
want to handle your dilution plates and
how you want to set up your qpcr plate
we've done all our testing using the
Kappa biosystems library quant kits
however we can actually alter this
method to work with any other qpcr kit
type if requested the last method is the
normalization and pulling method and in
this one again you have to enter the
number of samples anywhere from 1 to 96
and you also input the options that you
use for your qpcr and the average
fragment size you want to use so they
can get a more accurate quant and you
also select whether or not you want to
run pulling the reason we didn't know
your qpcr setup is that the
normalization pulling the first thing it
does it pops up the spreadsheet and the
spreadsheet is very simple to use
there's three basic steps one you import
your raw qpcr data to you enter the
volume and concentration that you want
to normalize two and three you collect
the export data to biomech button the
spreadsheet actually has a lot on that's
going on here and it's kind of hard to
show in this webinar there's a separate
tab that handles your cooling and you
can either heart code you're pulling
options if you're running the same
process each time or if you want to
change your pulling volumes and
destination wells it actually allows you
to set this each time you run there's
also some error checking those built in
as you can see from the red text if
anyone wants more information on the
normalization method
or any of the methods that I've talked
about please feel free to go to the
beckman coulter booth after this talk
and I'll be hanging around so that I can
answer any questions finally you can see
the timing for the instrument when
running the alumina stranded and more'n
a cat here Zach and I broke it down into
a two day process where day one with
cdna synthesis and it took about five
hours to run 96 samples day two was our
library construction day and it took
about four hours to run 90s examples and
now for the more important part of our
presentation I'm going to pass it back
to zag so you can talk about the data
that we generated using this aluminum
methods be thank you very much Mary so
as part of our only control of dis
automation that we did two separate
sequencing runs one a 24 sample library
construction run that was run on the my
seek here locally at the CTB and then we
also did a 96 sample library
construction run that which 30 samples
were sequenced at a luminous facility on
a high C 2000 instrument so I'm going to
now just dive into the my seek data so
for the 24 sample my seek test we ran
mostly Daphne appeal X on RNA samples so
the plate layout during library
construction you can see on your left in
this slide there's a large number of
daphnia samples there are human
Universal reference are any samples from
Agilent at various concentrations
running from 100 nano grams 2.5 are the
two micrograms of total RNA going into
the library construction there's also a
couple of arabidopsis samples the
Daphnia and analysis RNA were provided
by researchers here on campus the plate
was laid out in such a way that we could
use the sequencing results to assess
whether or not the automation was
carrying samples over during the course
of library construction humans daphnia
and rabid opsys are quite divergent and
we are confident that we can tell
difference between those reads if we
hadn't say human reads that carried over
into daphnia samples and so on so that's
the logic behind our plate layout at the
end of library construction we ran the
libraries out on the Agilent tape
station 2200 instrument which if
anyone's familiar with it it's very
similar the agilent bioanalyzer except
it's more amenable to high-throughput
projects and so you can see the
electropherogram traces on the bottom
right and then false gel images of being
library size distributions on just above
that and so the library results were
very consistent size and fairly
consistent in concentrations at the end
of library construction so we were very
happy with these results so after
sequencing we sent the data for the
universal human reference RNA libraries
to our colleagues at illumina who have
specially designed by automatics
pipelines to use this information or to
map these reeds and to assess how well
the weeds are mapping to the human
reference genome which in this case is
HD 18 as you can see our percent
alignments leads in the second to the
left-hand column are very high we're
getting over a eight percent alignment
with only about anywhere from two to
three percent of the raids with
unaligned abundant needs and we're also
quite low reiben human ribosomal and
ribosome will find a subunit reads are
extraordinarily low in this run which
indicates that the ribosomal removal
that we employed during the course of
library construction on this run work
quite well and we saw very low
percentages of mitochondrial DNA reads
and adapter timers so we were very happy
that these libraries are performing
quite well in these two charts what you
the base counts in Giga bases are on the
left hand on the y-axis in both charts
throughout the human universal human
reference libraries
for our daphnia libraries these grafts
here do have also the cute in addition
to the total bases which are in red the
q30 bateman sorry total bases were in
blue and the cute 30 bases in red so the
quality scores or q30 scores are
indicative of extraordinarily high
competence in the base calls of these
libraries and so what we're producing
here are libraries that are very
consistent size and the base calling is
extraordinaires quite accurate so we're
very happy with these results as well
locally our bio fermentations here at
the center for genomics also went
through the bother of napping each of
the libraries 23 23 different potential
reference genomes on this plate the
human daphnia arab analysis for human we
use the HT 18 reference genome we use
the ter 10 reference genome for rabid
opsys and we use the TCO genome for
Daphne Pollux that's available on w flea
bass and so if you look at the data we
have the library on the far left the
total number of reads and then the
number of reads and the percent reads
for each library that potentially might
map to a different reference gym so for
example in there daphnia k 13 library we
had 238 leads that maps potentially to
human after these leads are very low
from a total lead standpoint the
percentages are quite now normal men
you'd and on further investigation of
these reads we determine these to be
mostly conserved sequences between
genomes so we're confident from the
micing data that we're we're not
observing a cross contamination problem
so those results encourage us to up to
scale quite a bit so our second quote QC
run we did the whole 96-well plate
here's the plate layout it's very
colorful but if you'll bear with me I
can explain it all all the red wells you
see on this play parts NATO libraries we
have the universal human reference RNA
libraries in yellow drosophila
melanogaster in the peach
we have some data yup you Lex libraries
in blue as well as tribolium libraries
in purple so it's a very mixed plate
researchers here on campus are working
on a wide variety of organisms so this
is a very good test for us and again the
plate was layout laid out in such a way
that we could use it to determine
whether how cross-contamination was an
issue so again at the end of library
construction we ran the finish libraries
through the Agilent 2200 pay station
unit and our consistency of library prep
is very high we were extraordinarily
pleased with these results so average
size was about three hundred base pairs
or so it's just good up to 96 libraries
30 of them were selected for and sent to
aluminum for sequencing on a high seek
2004 two lanes of a 75 cycle paired
emblem and a luminous pipeline was
focused primarily on the university
human reference RNA libraries as before
so as you can see from this chart we
have large number of you know that we're
looking in the tens of millions of reads
for each of these libraries that are
passing their quality filters for both
we've won and me too and our percent
filter pass reed's of base is greater
than q30 scores are very high so if you
look on the on the y-axis we're starting
this at eighty-two percent which is
extraordinarily good our percent
alignments for both lead 1 and V 2 in
the universal human reference libraries
here are presented in red we had high
alignments higher in read one than I
need to because quality scores tend to
drop him to dip a little bit during beat
two but on balance these look really
good our percent rival zonal leads were
low except for a couple of libraries we
observe some slightly higher percentages
of ribosomal sequence only attribute
this to a localized problem with library
construction for those samples usually
the chemistry is very robust removing
right
are more correctly at room at capturing
the messenger RNA and moving it forward
and rather than leaving our ribosomal
RNA amount to be a reverse transcribed
our percent duplicates were very low for
being a universal human reference
samples they're somewhat higher for the
tomatoes but that's not terribly
surprising given the repetitiveness in
LAN genomes and our percent median CV
coverage so when we're looking at the
coverage of the transcripts across the
link of the travail of the any
particular transcript was pretty close
to one so this graph and another 1 i'll
be showing later seemed to indicate that
we're not observing any bias towards the
five prime to three prime ends very
importantly this is the percent correct
strand orientation for e to the
libraries so specifically we're going to
the entire global doing stranded RNA see
is to preserve the stranded RNA into the
Strand information during the course of
library construction as you can see from
the human libraries here on this samples
we had reads assigned to the correct
strand over ninety eight percent of the
time for these libraries and that was
exhale a very we were extremely happy
with these results it shows that this
elaborate construction technique is
actually doing what we would wanted it
to do and again this is a plot showing
the distribution of leads over the
opening particular position of a
transcript so as you can see where we're
generating libraries that are not biased
towards the five prime or three point
ends additionally our colleagues at
illumina napped their leads to you know
the 2d human reference genome and
determine not surprisingly that the vast
majority of our messenger RNA leads or
coming from coding regions or
untranslated region 3 utr regions we see
lower council rates coming to intronic
our intergenic
spaces inside the human genome which is
good that's exactly what we were hoping
to see and then finally as far as
analyzing the 96 sample run our bio
competitions here the CTB mapped each of
the libraries to its to all potential
reference libraries on the on the plate
and so as you can see here what we have
cassava to NATO human and tribolium
libraries our goose offal library is
mapped overwhelmingly to just to the
drosophila reference genome as likewise
for our human libraries our tomato and
tribolium libraries did Matt also
primarily to those genomes the orange
bars you can send these graphs are all
unassigned reads we don't really
necessarily observe leads that are being
mapped to be incorrect reference genome
the larger numbers of larger percentages
of unassigned reads the tomato and
tribolium libraries are more indicative
of the current state of those reference
genomes so drosophila and human are
extraordinarily well worked on systems
and tribolium and to nato read the
reference genomes just simply are not as
as good as for drosophila human and so
this is just a numbers presentation of
that previous slide that I showed you
with the mappings of each of each
species to its reference genome so we
have the species of the library the
total weeds and then each of the
reference genomes that it was mapped to
so as you can see we're not really
observing significant numbers of leads
that are mapping to incorrect reference
genomes so this would indicate that the
library construction method is not
causing sample cross contamination
during hybrid construction
so with that we can draw two major
conclusions that the automation of the
stranded mrna library prep kit from
aluminum results in higher sample
throughput with less time and less money
and the libraries that we are
constructing the consolidation solution
are very high quality in burza and
provide good results for sequencing
while being free of cross-contamination
and with that I'd like to acknowledge
the hard work of our colleagues our
glare and Lisa Jackson at beckman
coulter ten hill Dave Delano and
alejandra gutierrez at alumina and my
supervisor dr. Scott Michaels and myself
instead of the genomics and
bioinformatics and so with that I would
like to pass the presentation back to
our moderator or at least Jackson hello
everyone again Thank You Zach Mary and
aid for a very interesting presentation
that was excellent and hopefully
everyone can hear me because I had lost
my connection there for a minute we're
going to go right into our Q&A session
and feel free to type in questions as
we're going through this it looks like
we have a few questions the first one is
for Zach Smith and that is was the
method developed in conjunction with I
you or did I you receive the already
optimized method in either case how long
did it take to get to a fully
implemented method and with that I will
pass it over to you Zach thank you Lisa
I you do not receive any optimized
method we built this with beckman
coulter from the ground up we were it
was advantageous that we didn't have to
rework most of the chemistry or to make
it work on the automation but between
Mary glare and myself we built this
automation solution from
ground up and it took us it took us a
few weeks to get it up and running
there's a lot of advanced scripting
that's involved in this method and
there's a lot of optimization that takes
place when you're moving from a manual
to an automated solution for library
construction you know you're just
testing shaking times and making sure
that you're delivering the correct
volumes to to perform what the chemistry
is capable of doing so yeah leave a we
built this one from the ground up norm
quite proud of it I'll pass it back to
Lisa now okay so i think this question
is also for you Zach and Mary may want
to add on to it or i may add on to it
after depending on how you end up with
your answer what throughput justifies
automation and how many my see customers
have automated any type of NGS sample
preparation with that I'll turn it back
over to you Zach thank you Lisa so in my
mind any any amount of sample prep that
exceeds eight samples justifies
automation you know my facility is a
small fasala JH our university core
facility were limited on our staff and
so but we do have a large department
doing lots of interesting research and
they are interested in turning their
samples around quickly and reliably and
they want to make sure that they get the
best investment for their money so so
here at the cg b we charge our customers
based off of a sliding scale on a number
of libraries that we're going to prep
because it does increase you know if
you're doing it manually there's large
amounts peak recent time largely and
ignition time basically so we tried to
automate anything that we were doing
above eight samples simply as it is more
cost effective to do it without nation
than it is
to do it manually we're here talking
anything beyond eight as far as my see
customers are concerned we have a number
of labs on campus that are interested in
bacterial sequencing and bacterial
genomes are small enough that library
construction cost is really the biggest
driver in determining how many samples
they do because the genomes are small
you can easily get you know how the next
coverage if you're just talking about a
single my secret and so for our
microbial research community they're
very interested in prepping as many
samples as they can as as efficiently
and cheaply as they can even if they're
only running it on my seat so I think
that automation service both of my seat
and the high seat platforms very well I
think that given the quick turnaround
time on the my sink you can also do
larger numbers of more more complex
organisms so you care in eukaryotic
systems and so yeah I think I think it's
a sista it's a solution that works well
for both platforms and with that I will
turn it back over to Lisa okay so thanks
for that answer and we're going to give
you a workout here the next question is
for you also and it's what percentage of
barcode weeds are perfect and what do
you do you do with the barcode weeds
that are one base pair off and with that
I'll give it back to use back well thank
you Lisa um so for large numbers of
multiplex samples we really can't afford
to have any ambiguity in the bar code
base calling and so when we're
demultiplexing our libraries we tend to
throw beads or that we're bar codes were
not assigned we tend to discard those
and those are a banishing Lee small
subset of any particular experiment
usually much less than one person
occasionally what you can do with my
secret porter software is you can add
random basis if you're
concern that they're going to be
particularly troublesome base calling
events but really the best thing you can
do as a researcher is to make sure that
you're using our code and combinations
that are complementary to each other and
in accordance with voluminous
recommendations usually the strongest
problem that researchers have when we're
doing multiplex samples is that we have
index sequences that are too alike and
which then result in the loss of cluster
acquisition during sequencing and so
making sure that you understand what bar
codes are putting into any particular
sequencing run and hence any library
construction run that you might do is
very important from a sample planning
and from an experiment planning stage
and so with that I will pass it back to
Lisa hoping that I have answered okay
and I will give a few seconds here in
case anyone else wants to enter a
question or in case you want it
elaboration on any of the questions that
were answered and with that it looks
like no one is typing so I would like to
thank the audience for attending today
we really appreciate it again I
encourage you to visit our booth for
some additional chat you can download
information on our genomic products and
solutions for NGS and other applications
like extraction for DNA and RNA
purification size selection also we have
a survey going on in our booth and if
you fill out the survey survey you'll be
entered in a drawing for one of two
iPads so do stop by and once again thank
you very much and that's the end of our
presentation